hello freak [ __ ] okay so I am known
as this male feminist which again and it
kind of becomes my thing so I go on your
show we argue about it because I'm like
I don't have comic friends anymore so I
take this side and I didn't hear all
about the rape joke like I just heard
all the whole Daniel Tosh story I heard
at the Stanhope show for the first time
because the articles I read don't have
the nuanced parts right so all I let's
explain what actually has not supposed
to be on stage that night Daniel Tosh
was just hanging out The Laugh Factory
and his good friend Don my rare I asked
him to go up and he said I'll go okay I
don't have anything to talk about he
goes on stage everybody goes crazy oh my
god Daniel Tosh is here this is amazing
and he goes look he was I don't have any
material I'm not even supposed to be up
here so what do you guys want to talk
about what you know and some guy yells
out rape and he goes yeah he goes yeah
that's real funny sir what's funny about
rape the humiliation that violence and
this woman yells out actually nothing's
funny about rape like very
self-aggrandizing and he goes wouldn't
be funny in five guys raped her right
now right that that's the funny part so
like what a comedian does so that line
was the the line that was circulating
but even that first part not that that
part was ignored conveniently the whole
part where he's just like what's funny
about it and like that's a good
technically that's an anti rape joke
right
you know Daniel that's how he thinks
right it's not he's not a bad guy no
that's a great way but that has to do
with these echo chambers where my one
[ __ ] hear that part of it I just hear
the part you just hear the part that
you're supposed to attack and then you
know ironically I went to one of Burt's
podcasts at the the same festival that
all things Comedy Festival and [ __ ]
Doug and Bert like this whole rape thing
happened in the audience I don't know if
you heard about it but like No all hell
broke loose in the audience yeah so like
I don't want to be the one to blow up
the spot I don't know if Bert's gonna
air it if he's gonna if he if he airs
the
take off from work podcast or whatever
it's one of the best things I've ever
heard but this we call him right now
yeah because I don't want to blow up a
spot but essentially what happened was
they Stanhope it'll just get people to
listen good
Stanhope started talking about rape and
child rape and the whole show became
very rape themed right and there was a
girl next to me and there's a woman next
to me my girlfriend who just started
screaming like they'll talk about it and
like said they ignored her the whole
time and my girlfriend and I would look
over and then she would like have
another sip of her drink and watch the
show and giggle and then rape would come
out but she was like stop tied you just
screamed but like she didn't she didn't
she shouldn't leave like shouldn't get
up and leave and that was like it was so
interesting to be on like sort of the
opposite end of that where you know
nothing offensive was really happening
I'm like [ __ ] mana I'm next to that lady
from the tosh.o this is this is like my
karmic fate and I'm just like she should
go she should leave but anyways so I was
on the not kamek side of that and by
then I wasn't doing comedy clubs I was
never really accepted into comedy clubs
I'm just playing for my progressive
audience at like a vegan coffee house
like that's I'm just playing random like
little rock gigs for like my audience so
again echo-chamber
right and I'm not hanging out with
comics so when people are like why
aren't you defending a comic I'm like I
don't know man cuz I don't think I am
one like I didn't really consider myself
one and so yeah so me and you me and you
went at it I believe it was very
divisive I think half your audience
thought I was a whiny [ __ ] and the
other half thought I was a whiny [ __ ]
you should get raped
it was very one-sided nobody liked me I
was I did not come off well I'm told and
but I was like I guess I did the right
thing right I guess I sided with women
over over jokes and so from then on any
comic that did like me didn't let me
stop you right there
yeah yeah you know just and I'm not
trying to sound a mistake to me by the
way yeah the sake of honesty the real
issue came not just because of that but
because of your characterization the
next thing yeah totally so the next day
there's
video out about it that someone put
together called the kill Steen delusion
yeah and some of the chip was taken out
of context some of that [ __ ] I will
completely like own up to I watched it
like once I mean at that point at that
point just all hell broke loose like I
lost my I lost my managers I was having
like a someone hacked my Twitter and
just wrote rape all over it and I was
kind of like did you lose your manager
uh they said it was because I don't
cooperate with the comedy community to
be fair to them I was like a
pain-in-the-ass client it was hard
enough for me to [ __ ] book and then
every comic eights mean they're like I
don't know man I think they just like
threw their hands up and so the next day
was one of those things where I'm like I
either doubled down and like and I was
like it wasn't like I'm like I'm gonna
lie it was I'm gonna try to defend
myself and give like you know my side to
it and that I don't know we'll stop here
real quick
[Applause]
[Music]